woman is now killed every three days in
the UK and we are joined now by the
concept of MP Laura Faris and Carol
Gould who is the mother of murdered
teenager Ellie Gould to discuss whether
enough has been done to tackle Islands
against women first of all thank you so
much for coming in obviously Laura it's
lovely to have you here but I'm really
very happy and you know humbled really
that you've taken the time out to come
and talk to us on what I know must be a
really difficult subject for you so we
really appreciate that thank you okay
thanks for having me it's important
things to discuss yeah absolutely right
um Laura do you want to just talk us
through your campaign and what's
happening now yeah well thank you again
for um showing an interest in this issue
this is the second part really of the
campaign we got the prohibition on the
so-called rough sex defense where it
said that the victim consented to fatal
injury in The Domestic Abuse Act and one
of the things that campaigners and MPS
felt at the time is that that was being
used as a defense often to avoid a
charge of murder and to get manslaughter
and often actually having it framed by
the court as an unfortunate accident
that was regrettable and probably partly
her fault too we got it into the
Domestic Abuse Act which made it a more
serious offense it was much more likely
than to be charged as unlawful at
manslaughter rather than gross
negligence man's daughter but there was
still a string of cases where people
were getting to rise of resentences less
than you could get for pet theft less
even actually in one or two cases the
sampaibus case being an example then the
maximum you could get for non-fatal
strangulation when he fatally strangled
his victim so I have been I had a
private members Bill actually and I've
been hammering on the door of the MOJ to
look again at sentencing on this and to
create a new starting point that puts it
into a higher sentencing bracket and
that's the effect of the announcement
this week that it that it is likely or
the the invitation will firstly be
extended to the sentencing Council but
there is a right to for the MOJ to
legislate if they don't that the new
starting point will be eight to twelve
years so so double figures uh as a
minimum and I think that you know must
fairly reflect the gravity of the crime
and frankly you know the depravity of
what's happened to the woman who has no
opportunity to give her side of of the
case I mean when you say that the
minimum sentence and eight to ten years
it feels like you know it's
extraordinary that's not happening
already and it hasn't happened already
and pet theft and potentially getting
more um breathtaking really
and Carol you've been campaigning
obviously
um since the death of your daughter can
you just tell us a little bit about what
happened to her whatever you're
comfortable with sharing obviously okay
so Ellie was in the sixth form she was
17 years old and halfway through her a
levels
um she started dating a fellow student
who was also in the sixth form
um it was a three-month relationship it
was her first boyfriend
um two months into the relationship he
then became controlling and she
described to her friends that he was
suffocating
um so she decided to end the
relationship she ended it on a Thursday
evening and she told me that she was
going to do that and on the Friday
morning while she was at home revising
he came to our house
he strangled her and then he picked up
her knife and he stabbed her 13 times in
the neck
if that wasn't bad enough he then
focused completely on himself he washed
his DNA off of the handle of the knife
he then put her hand in the knife into
her hand and reinserted it into her neck
to make it look like suicide and then he
just walked out of our house as though
nothing had happened completely focused
on himself covering up his tracks and
then my husband came home in the
afternoon and found his beloved daughter
in a pool of blood on our kitchen floor
it's horrendous and the sentence for
that
12 and a half years 12 and a half years
for the brutal murder of our
precious daughter that is the justice
system when it comes to violence against
women and girls
and sorry do you want to ask me another
question
it's disgusting is there was there a
reason well number one he was sentenced
as a child as a ten-year-old despite
being five years off his five months off
his 18th birthday and secondly because
murders in the home are seen as a lesser
crime it doesn't matter how violent they
are they're diminished and um as a
result of this Claire Wade review we're
hoping to push through some much tougher
sentencing and what I would be saying to
the government now and Dominic Rob is
you've not quite cut it yet just
offering aggravating factors for
Overkill and for
um and for Creative control and behavior
is not going to level up the sentence in
what we want and we will be asking
minister arga to consult on is a 25 year
starting point for Overkill and for
strangulation because we have to
remember that this is very much gendered
violence and it's just not being
recognized in the courts how dangerous
these perpetrators are can you just
explain what Overkill is what is
overcome well it's the excessive use of
force in a homicide so you may have
strangled the person but then you use a
weapon to do much more than necessary
yes and that's a in domestic homicide
that's present in 60 of cases I
thought what you say about gendered
killing and killings domestic which the
phrase itself domestic feels like a
completely the wrong word to use in
these sense as well I think that Rings
true with a lot of people including
myself
um
do you think that steps have been taken
to to recognize the I guess the
injustices in the system
well as a result of the clay Wade review
now domestic homicides have been put in
the spotlight and thanks to her review
is now highlighting particular
characteristics of these murders and how
violent they are how frenzied they are
um and as I say what a public risk these
perpetrators are to society
um but her recommendations don't go far
enough so we do have a meeting hopefully
with Minister arga after Easter and we
hope to discuss these things further
with him and push these starting points
to 25 years I mean I don't like to
compare cases but if you think of a high
profile case of Sabina Nessa horrific
murder and that perpetrator received a
sentence of 36 years if you compare that
to a domestic setting the same amount of
violence the same amount of suffering to
the vet in the same danger that these
people pose and in the case of poppy the
lady the daughter of the lady that I
campaign with he his his sentence was 16
years that's a 20-year difference how is
that how is that just because one took
place in a park and one took place in
the home
what's your sort of take on this about
the gendered nature of Earth yeah well I
think it's really important that the
government commissioned this review
because when you read it you realize
it's the first time that that specific
domestic context has been really looked
at and made an entire framework for a
potentially new sentencing uh regime and
one of the things I think that she
really draws on is firstly the absolute
breach of trust that often is inherent
to these cases sometimes happening for
example when the victim is asleep
um also the presence of coercive control
or some form of domestic abuse as a
precursor to the total offense before
the behavior before and just also the
existence in court of outdated language
like battered women's syndrome which is
sort of an old-fashioned word for what
we would Now understand is various forms
of more nuanced domestic abuse like
coercive control or economic control or
other things that have happened and I
just think it allows for a new framework
where we recognize
the vulnerability that some women have
after a long period but she is also I
have to say Claire Wade was also Sally
challenge Barrister and so she is also
very sensitive to the women who will
perhaps after a long history of domestic
abuse retaliate Sally challenge was um
and her sons have done some amazing
campaigns as well right and she suffered
domestic abuse for many years and then
went on to kill her so she's trying to
create a new sentencing framework that
will factor in the various impulses that
is fair to both sexes but recognizes the
pre-existing feature of domestic abuse
in the way that it can either aggravate
or mitigate depending on how the crime
unfolds I just wonder if you want to
take the opportunity to reflect a little
bit on your daughter at all and Ellie
and the kind of girl that she was and
the kind of achievements that she had I
totally understand if you prefer not to
but this is always the hard bit of any
interview but um yeah and he was
delightful she was delightful she was
really kind and caring very thoughtful
to her observers her friends often
described her as the glue amongst
different friendship groups because she
never liked anybody to be left out of
anything and she had a huge laugh at
animals
um in the you know when she was young we
always visited Farms to hold baby Lamb's
chicks and then her passion went on to
horses and she became a very you know an
excellent equestrian
um Rider and you know that that was her
passion at the weekends riding her Pony
and competing and
yeah and she has such a bright future
ahead of her you know she was looking at
joining the police force and she would
have given so much to society and you
know it's just such a Devastation that
she's been taken from us it sounds like
the kind of person that would have been
great in the police definitely she would
have done she was very balanced very
balanced she'd even completed a piece of
work as part of her a-level studies
ironically on should child murderers be
punished and she received the results
from that three days before her own
murder it's it's really quite chilling
and thank you so much for coming on the
program
um you speak unbelievably eloquently the
most difficult of circumstances and you
know you should feel that you're really
making an enormous amount of change here
well I feel like we're on the first rung
of the ladder we still got a big climb
to go yet but I hope the conservative
government are listening to us because
we are really not going let's go
to be honest thing because that their
initial response was interim they've
accepted a number of Claire Wade's
recommendations and there's going to be
further consultation on this so it's a
start it's a positive style voice is of
course really important we're helping
promised to be part of the consultation
process so we will hold them to that I'm
sure you will I don't have any doubt on
that whatsoever and thank you both so
much for coming on the program it's like
a real pleasure and a privilege for me
to be able to talk about this
thank you thank you